did you think you
make Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we G no value to haters how run homie
look what I become I'm the I'm the
one
okay home team man we got a lot of stuff
to cover that we have we haven't done a
home team for a minute it feels like I
forgot who you are yeah I it's a good to
meet you what's your name Vincent
Vincent you're you're the guy that wrote
the book The choose your enemies wisely
holy crap it's you comes out today just
so you know yes hey Valerie good to meet
you hey how you doing Val nice to meet
you where's
's you're going we'll see we'll see
what's going to happen with him Tom Tom
makes jokes a little bit you know
momentum of jokes get uh but anyway so
okay stories we got a lot of things to
talk about last week we were in La I was
in Vegas uh uh I was a couple different
places doing stuff for the podcast so we
haven't had any stories to cover but
we're here today and there's a lot of
insanity going on first of all there's a
building cops are going up to this
building all of a sudden blows up if you
haven't seen this we'll show you the
clip it's absolutely insane some people
want John Stewart to run for office
Rockets coach okay did you see this UD
udoka ejected after altercation with
LeBron you should see what he said to
LeBron Rob do you actually have the
words instead of playing the clip
because I know the NBA doesn't like it
when you show any kind of interaction if
he can get the exchange instead of the
clip that'd be great um hardly an
altercation yeah it's not an altercation
but it's an exchange they called it
maybe worse than an altercation cuz
words were caught up on social and a lot
of people are following up with the
words words that he said to LeBron Trump
is right that schools teach kids to hate
America that's why them staffers are
protesting for Hamas interesting story
by the way that's Bill Maher saying that
Tucker Carlson drops bombshell reveals
what got him fired with Fox News more
retired Americans are un retiring and
many worry about age discrimination
Derek shelvin is discharged from the
hospital after being stabbed 22 times by
who Vinnie can you give us a glimpse by
an a former FBI informant by former FBI
informant 22 times we'll get into that
story yeah California why does
California differs so much from uh Texas
we'll talk about the differences that's
an LA time story by the way uh Trump and
flips out at Robert Deno he should hear
what happens their credit card that
there's this new thing going on that
we'll talk about Tom I'm sure you got a
lot of data on this buy now pay later
it's Insanity what American people are
doing and why these buy out pay lader
companies are blowing up they have a
certain loophole they're using in that
allows them to not have to register with
the truth of lending credit correct and
allows them to get away with it I'm sure
you're going to get into that no hard
credit Che Bitcoin 42k Gold On The Rise
Black Friday Shoppers use buy now pay
later we'll talk about that Harvard
Professor prepares to teach a new
subject called Taylor Swift we'll talk
real estate we'll talk economy Spotify
about to lay off 17% of their staff I
don't think they're going to lay off one
of them I think that guy's name is Joe I
think they're going to have to keep that
guy but we'll see what happened the
santis was asked are you going to step
out and you know not compete anymore if
you lose Iowa The Exchange is
interesting Vinnie's got some stuff he
wants to talk about with Israel
Palestine Hamas Millennials feel
abandoned by parents not available to
help raise grandkids they're too busy
Millennials stick around for that one
maybe have your uh grandparents or your
parents listen to this but having said
that before we get into all these
stories today the book I've been working
on for the last three years choose your
enemies wisely comes out and
interestingly so this entire book is is
about planning it's about business
planning it's about life planning I
looked at Amazon and every time somebody
asks me for something the way I save the
conversation is if you're really serious
about this go read this book if you want
to find out about you know relationship
advice go read five love languages if
you want your wife if she's not
respecting you and you want something
read love and respect if you want to get
better with people cuz your military
background read how to win friends
there's so many books to recommend
there's not a book to recommend for
business planning so I decided to write
it if you have big plans for
2024 place an order this is on Amazon
and Barnes & Noble and by the way just
we we've never promoted this book on
this podcast anybody that orders this
book now okay if you order a book now
hard cover on Amazon you can go leave
the link in the chat and description if
you could if you order it now and you
email your receipt to enemies is it
vt.com if you email your receipt to
enemies at vt.com again enemies vt.com
by the end of it we will pick five of
you and our friends here are going to
give us a five names and I'm going to
send you physically I'll send you f uh a
signed copy of choose your enemies
wisely and if you're like me I order
hard cover and audiobook because I like
to listen to the audiobook when I'm
reading the book and there's three big
stories I say in the Audi book that's
not in the physical book so place the
order of both and we'll do raffle for
five at the end so having said that
uh Saturday I will also be at the Barnes
& Noble Boer Ron doing a doing autograph
and doing what time is what time is that
I think it's at 1:00 is what we'll give
you more details if you're in Florida
area South Florida area I'll be a Bo can
I come as security you're going to have
to come at going you have we're going
together I need protection okay Adam
it's good to have you on thank you sir
okay all right so let's go to the first
story uh can you pull up the story of uh
uh the one I just emailed you uh Insider
of saying how many times they're
planning to lower rates in 2024 so check
this out the Federal Reserve will cut
interest rates six times in 20124 as
economy shows clear signs of cooling
down in says Tom how much how much Intel
and stories and research have you done
on this topic because if they lower the
rate six times is this four quarters 15
one half of bases 1 3/4s what's it going
to look like you know um you know I've
been on let's dive into this uh you know
I've been on this page I think that
there's probably five to six reductions
next year quarter point8 so that's about
a point and a half uh off the five and a
quarter where we're sitting right now
next year starting at the beginning of
Q2 uh and there is actually there's a
small graph on this uh Rob little
stairstep graph so people can kind of
see it so there you can see all the
increases that went up and there's the
dotted lines of the five coming down
next year this I've been anti
anticipating this Jamie diamonds I'm on
the same page and the same logic that
Jamie Diamond has on this that the FED
really wants to let all of this get
through the end of the year like food
poisoning to let these rate increases
stop inflation get it back to 2% and
then next year it comes down all you
have to do to get uh mortgage rates is
put two points on whatever that is so
this means mortgages are probably still
going to be six and a half uh at the end
because you see it's a little over four
by the end of 25 so mortgage rat are
still going to be about 6 and A2 and so
this is this is what we're looking at
and the Intel that I see is that this is
what's going to happen it's going to be
gradual it's not going to zip back down
even if the economy's got issues it's
going to gradually come down because the
fed's going to do it now people are
trying to bring things up right now you
hear a lot of the banking Community
trying to say things now maybe we should
start earlier but the reason they want
that is if the interest rates go down
quicker Corporate America can get
lending and expand is probably going to
make stocks go up faster next year so
there's a there's a a motivation in
there and it's not a bad motivation but
a motivation nonetheless but this is
exactly what I've anticipated and with
the exception that if we really have a
bad fourth quarter if GDP is really low
maybe the FED does its first cut March
but most people are thinking April right
there at the beginning of second quarter
so if if this is the case this is very
good news for the market this also means
real estate that hasn't dropped at all
is going to go higher if it hasn't
dropped at all because Realtors are
going to go around saying hey what are
you talking about here's what's going to
happen this is what's going on with the
interest rates you know real estate's
going to be Skyrocket and if there's not
a if there's not a major disruption
taking place wouldn't Realtors be
salivating over over a story like this
that they can wait till the end of the
year or half way around to you know
lower the rates yes I think so right
it's like right now you you go out and
you say wow you know what are interest
rates right now for average credit I
think I think they slipped a little bit
like 7 a qu 7 and a half uh they came
down a little bit and so a good mortgage
broker is going to say hey Tom you're
thinking a buying a place and you don't
like the seven and a half interest rate
look by the end of next year what's it
going to be six 6 and a half this is a
new normal so if you're really thinking
about it and you like this house these
prices aren't going to bottom out you
should think about pulling the trigger
and doing it if you've got the cash to
put the down and do it so I think you're
exactly right that the mortgage industry
is going to play this like hey man it's
the new normal if you're on the
sidelines with enough cash but you like
that
house the bottoms not going to drop out
of this Market you should go buy it I
think that's going to be their sell what
what a what a unpredictable economy
we've been in to see this taking place
by the way Rob can you pull up uh go
pull up average 30-year fixed rates
right now just Google average 30 rate
30-year fixed average 30-year mortgage
rate there you go right there yeah
Google got the thing now watch this the
average credits and go to another page
and type type in average credit score in
America average credit score in America
yeah so let's just see what it says it
should be around 718 day you go okay so
if it's 718 go back to the prior page
that means that number right there is
700 to 719 so on a $300,000 loan today
if you got a 30-year fixed you're
looking at 7.97 4% that's a very that's
pretty much you can say 8% is what
you're looking at but the FHA and the VA
you see they're down about seven so
we're on a national like seven and a
half right now we're on a national seven
and a half right now so if they lower it
six times at minimum Tom that's a point
and a half right oh yeah if we're
National seven and a half I think for
really good credit will be like National
6 six and the eighth at the end of next
year if they take six drops of a quarter
point which is one in a half brings it
down to three and A2 add two that's 6
and a half for mortgages so so you don't
think they're going to do a single one
of them above a quarter you think
they're all going to be quarter quarter
quarter you don't think he's going to do
one at a half or three quarters um
currently no but let's wait and see what
happens in Q4 because the consumers out
of gas you mentioned a couple other
stories we're going to cover today and
uh wh why would they uh because when he
raised it it was all basically 50 basis
points right um fight inflation fight
inflation fight inflation and they went
pretty steep how many of the cut the or
the ra that he did were 25 versus 5050
basis points he did a couple that were
25 the last three were a couple yeah I
thought the last four were exactly 25
exactly but on the way down do you think
he goes 25 25 25 25 just the whole way
down yeah I think this fed does Jerome
Powell I think think he does because
remember when the FED drops fast they're
trying to prevent you know um stagnation
with the recession which is some people
called depression and to to get around
it they say oh the Great Recession
because they don't want to use the dword
they they pull those out when you've got
major Calamity I think he's going to sit
on the quarters and unless there's
something that really pushes him it's
going to be the first meeting in April
where drone pal said inflation has been
tamed uh yes there's some pain there's a
little bit of you know unemployment has
come back up again but now we see way
CLA just take a quarter and I think you
even see in this article that I think we
referenced this was the axio article
basically saying the war of inflation is
mostly one they sort of declared Victory
on inflation was where that goes Tom
just do me one favor please alert my
good friend Vinnie when he should put a
down payment on house I was just going
to say this is the time I was going to
say two things Tom I was going to say
number one I'm going to be in apartment
for a while with something like this
number one number two what was that rate
pth that almost 8% four years ago what
was it 3% 3% yeah 3% just 22 months ago
so biomics is just let's go keep that
keep that thing going right but but I
tell you what you know what they're
going to do next year when when these
rates come down I
there's a part of me that
feels um yeah there's a part of me that
feels that we're going to go back to
fake success again we always do yeah I
but again that's not a that's not a good
thing for us to go back to fake success
he rob okay so check this out this
transitions into the next story watch
this next story and this is the cause of
fake success okay and we'll talk about
this new thing that's taking place
that's very very hot that's making
companies a lot of money I'll tell you
what the format is and you'll see why
these two kind of add up with what we're
talking about with interest rates so how
America racked up a trillion dollars of
credit card bill this is a CNBC
story a trillion dollars uh is what we
have right Americans have amassed a
historic trillion dollars in credit card
debt driven by Soaring interest rates
due to Federal Reserve rate hikes
average interest rates for credit cards
have reached 22% over 22% with retail
credit cards nearing ready 20 9% that
means if you have $110,000 in debt that
debt is going to be
$20,000 in 2 and a half years that's
what 29% means putting a financial
burden on consumers rising cost of
Essentials like rent groceries and gas
of couple with with high borrowing rates
have left people feeling financially
stagnant despite this a record number of
consumers shop that's the key number
record number of consumers shop during
Thanksgiving holiday weekend with over
200 million hitting the store slight L
more than in 2022 some big box retailers
including Macy's and Nordstoms have
expressed concerns about a slow down in
credit card repay repayments posing a
risk to Holiday retail uh uh uh Revenue
by the way so who in here can you do me
a favor run run up a poll Rob and ask
did has anybody in the last 12 months
has used the buy now pay later option
have you used the buy now pay later
option have you used companies such as a
firm I think it's Clara you know PayPal
Apple have you used any of those just
use have you bought anything with buy
not pay a later option yes no that's all
we need to talk about that story leads
to this next one and then time we'll go
into you more Black Friday Shoppers use
buy now pay later even as they shunned
Big Ticket gifts okay so what are you
talking about early holiday shopping
data show that consumers are
increasingly turning to buy not pay
later services like a firm Clara
afterpay with $7.3 billion spent through
these Services as of Monday the trends
aligns with expectations that bmpl Bina
pay letter usage will reach $17 billion
this holiday season and increase of 177%
from the previous year as in indicated
by Adobe October's estimate Tom I have
some thoughts on this but I'll go to you
first what are your thoughts when you
see numbers like this well I I'll add to
your number with Cyber Monday that7
billion number you just quoted Pat
became 9.3 billion wow in bmpl so right
now why do people use bmpl 20% of
consumers that apply for bmpl and by
this comes from payments which is a um
kind of a watchdog and a um a market
research firm that covers credit cards a
lot of things 20% of consumers said that
the reason they use bmpl was to bypass a
credit check because they don't want to
hurt their credit score or they weren't
going to be able they were going it's
called the soft credit check is what
they call it yep so check this out BPL
was up 47% Black Friday last year it was
11% this year it's 18% and 20% of
customers said that they would apply for
it so the real data is showing up check
this out as well this is kind of
dangerous um here we
go half of people in a survey that was
taken after Black Friday said they would
have postponed or cancelled the purchase
of an item $500 or more that they Ed
bnpl if bnpl wasn't available
translation I couldn't afford it and I
and I didn't have credit to do it so I
chose bmpl so I think we need to look at
bmpl delinquencies and q1 and see what's
going on there and people 30% of the
survey respondents said that it was the
lower non non-existent interest rates
for instance there are some most people
don't know bnpl when Best Buy says bnpl
through a firm build paid through your
PayPal you will get zero interest rates
if you make the four payments and have
it paid off by March 1st so December
January February March you pay that it's
zero interest rate so most people said
they went for the zero interest rate and
no credit check and we had 9.3 billion
used which was up 47% from last year
check this out do do uh so couple other
things Vinnie how familiar are you with
bmpl Adam are you familiar with at all
uh I don't recommend it but I am
familiar with it I always see it but I
always wonder how is that how is it
related to like like a credit card which
is basically buy now pay later so check
this out here's how it works give you a
little bit of insight Tom did a great
job explaining it but I'm interested in
the format right so so the question
becomes why the hell would I use a
credit card over a bmpl what's the
difference that's the first question
everybody asked I was just going to say
what's the difference between bmpl
and a uh uh uh credit card the way go to
Clara's market cap the last few years
here's what these guys came up with when
the the truth in lending whatever came
out that that they started checking and
making credit card companies more
tighter because of the amount of money
they were making all this stuff the
pressure they got new credit card
company business was kind of on the down
people like okay what am I going to do
now what they Define as a credit card is
you making four payments or more if you
make four four payments or more so for
example you buy this phone okay for
$1,000 you decide to pay this off in 10
payments of a 100 credit card if I buy
this book for 40 bucks and I'm able to
make four payments of $10 that's a
credit card anything less than four
payments doesn't go through the the act
of you know the truth act and lending
okay act that they came up with for
credit cards so what these guys did the
buy not pay later it's three payments so
I buy this phone it's $1,000 I pay 250
up front they don't consider that as a
payment they consider that as a down
payment wow then I make three payments
of 250 the next 6 weeks 250 250 250 so
six weeks later I've paid the phone off
for what $1,000 so now the question
becomes okay the customer's happy CU
they got the phone and they were able to
pay it in four in three payments and
then the the the actual product
developer is happy cuz they sold the
phone for $1,000 but why the hell would
there be a business model for this
here's why because Clara goes to Apple
and says hey we'll offer this to your
customers but you got to give us 2 to 8%
on the back end which means what so if
you sell this for 1,000 bucks you
negotiate it with the
retailer so let's just say the retailer
negotiates 4% so if you buy this at
$1,000 and I give the bmpl you're going
to give me upfront how much on ,000 40
bucks so Clara makes 4% on a th000
that's 40 bucks and like we'll take that
risk we'll go ahead and get with that
and make the payment soft credit check
they're not doing a full-blown credit
check on you here's a problem you miss
one payment of the three you know what
the interest rate goes to what 30% on
the entire purchase so it goes from
1,000 bucks to $1300 23% of people that
have used the buy now pay later are
sitting there saying this was a terrible
experience this is Clara's valuation by
the way look at the valuation there to
the right October 8 2018 it was worth
$2.5 billion then it went to 5.5 billion
then it went to $10.6 billion then it
went to $31 billion then it went to $46
billion back down to $6 billion now this
buy now pay later model you know who
it's going to work for you know who just
launched a buy now pay lader last month
apple on October 23rd just launched a
buy now pay lader only to their
customers in America now here's the
thing guess why Apple's not worried
about this model why do you think
Apple's not worried about it go ahead
and don't pay it yeah go and not make
the payment you know what Apple can lock
you down from using your phone wow
iTunes
they can shut you off for social media
so guess why this is a phenomenal model
for Apple phenomenal model for Apple not
for others PayPal good model you don't
pay it PayPal can come and say you can
no longer bid on eBay there's so many
different things with this buy not pay
later the reality of it is it goes back
down to uh uh they avoided getting
license like an insurance imagine
selling insurance or real estate you
need a license and you're like man how
can I sell insurance without getting
license these companies were able to
start a credit card company without
calling it a credit card company calling
it a buy now pay later phenomenal model
by the way figure terrible for know the
rule to know the rules to kind of go
consumer yeah well fintech comes out of
Silicon Valley that's where it starts
most of it and what does Silicon Valley
think about the word starts with d
disrupting so how do I disrupt read the
laws read the laws hey if we do this we
could create this kind of a company a
fintech company that does this this and
this and so they're smart they read the
laws they put it up they didn't make the
loophole in the laws that's the way the
laws written and they built a company to
serve it um and now the American
Consumer is even greater greater debt
and it kind of hides behind the surface
check this out you know how people say
well 30% is not a lot of money what's 2
to 8% let's do the mat together watch
this watch this Vinnie I want you to pay
attention to this so if I buy it at
$11,000 okay they get 2 to 8% within how
long within 6 weeks right is when the
service is done okay what's 52 weeks
divided by six it's roughly
8.7 okay if you're tracking with me
what's 2 * 8.7 because it's minimum two
to 8% they get from the retailer right
what's 2 * 8.7 it's 17%
18% what's 8 *
8.7 65 70%
they're making
roughly return on their money 17 to 70%
yeah that's insane because they're
getting the 2 to eight point from the
retailer giving it to these companies
like Clara brilant but you know what the
problem is today why they're getting
destroyed in the last 18 months interest
rates money was cheap they kept doing it
now they're not getting money they're
they're getting destroyed with interest
so interest rates are putting out
putting these companies out of business
there buying a pay later businesses
PayPal's going to be fine with this
Apple's going to be fine with this the
smaller guys that are getting started
with it even a firm is doing pretty good
Clara is getting crushed I'm just not a
fan of this because it's destroying the
consumer it's hurting the consumer it's
another thing to tell you consumers
don't have a lot of savings it's the
lowest savings rate we've had in America
and God knows decades we are not saving
any money we're getting into more and
more debt why are we getting into more
and more debt because during covid daddy
and mommy the US government taught us
hey don't worry about it if you can't
pay your bills we'll send you stimulus
we'll stimulate you a little bit on
behalf of the government poor you little
you responsible father and mother that
are supposed to take care so American
people are like babe don't worry about
it if we go broke the government's going
to send us a check like they did during
covid that's exactly what you're raising
right now in this generation and I'll
show you something else that I dug up on
this and the research you know who's in
on this in a big way the online
retailers specifically Amazon they have
been doing studies trying to prevent
cart abandonment what is cart
abandonment well you go to Amazon you
put a couple things in your cart and you
don't check out you don't buy them and
they have been attempting to reduce cart
abandonment so they've been in
partnership with a firm and Clara and
using the loophole so that they only
have to say so much so if it's not on
your credit card or if a credit card is
denied they they put an interstitial ad
up right there if you click here through
Amazon and a firm you can still buy buy
what you wanted to buy right now so the
online retailers are pushing these
mental games in the face of the consumer
to get them why would the online
retailer care they're they're they're
making their money correct but what the
point is the online retailer has turned
to bnpl to solve a marketing problem
which is online cart abandonment did you
get
that okay so so how you're you're
familiar with premium financing of
course okay so Tom you're familiar with
premium financing yeah absolutely guys
this is the story of Premium financing
in insurance the rumor has it and the
myth has it that a former professional
NFL player figured this thing out and
turn it into an industry let me give you
the story all right this guy goes to
this insurance agent he says hey man I
want to buy a big policy it's like
101020 million policy he okay great your
premium is going to be $300,000 $400,000
whatever the number is he says all right
cool I'd like to finance that premium
the agent says what yeah I want to
finance my premium you know you don't
Finance the premium you take the money
out of your pocket and you give me a
check and you said no I don't want to do
that I want to go Finance it you can't
do that he says says Who and the
insurance agent's like well that's
actually a good question I don't know if
we can do that or not so the this
football player goes to the bank
finances the premium of the insurance
policy, gets the agent the $300,000
upfront the insurance policy is paying
him whatever 4% every year he's using
that to pay the interest on the loan at
the bank and the agent makes Couple
hundred, commission he says holy
let's call it premium financing so
there's three parties involved in
premium financing there's the client
there's the agent the bank there's the
insurance company okay guess who L
premium financing the agent loved it oh
yeah guess who originally initially
liked premium financing the carriers the
carriers love it I I sold more that's
right the car like dude what the hell
are we doing working with these guys
they're giving us a th000 policies at
$1,000 this one guy just gave us a
$100,000 or million dollar we would much
rather do fewer policies less leg work
for us you know what they learned a few
years later the agents were making
Vinnie there were guys crazy Vinnie I'm
not going to give names there's there's
some guys who made so much money they
bought professional soccer teams in
Europe shut up no shut up shut up man
they bought professional soccer teams in
Europe called premium financing a few
years later they
realize we got a reg this is
getting a little out of hand because
then clients interest rates were
changing couldn't pay the payments
clients are unhappy a lot of things I
think this buy not pay later reminds me
of Premium financing well that's if
there's anybody that can speak to this
for days on end it's my business because
when I came into the insurance business
I didn't go the typical insurance agent
route I went the almost the reverse
mortgages of life insurance which is
called life settlement so I got sort of
thrusted into this industry and the the
sort of like the PS to everything that
they were doing in the Premium Finance
industry was two years later because
they would wait till after the
contestability period so anybody that
has life insurance understands there's
the 2year CNS Clause the contestability
and suicide clause so that and you ever
see like making a murderer they're like
yeah she murdered her husband it's like
go check if they had some life insurance
first thing first thing so you you can't
really offload or sell your life
insurance cuz your life insurance is an
asset you can't have to wait two years
so what happened is all these agents
that were making all this money all
these older wealthier clients were
basically getting free coverage for two
years the premiums were being financed
by some entity some hedge fund some
investor what have you the pre the as
Pat mentioned the carriers were taking
in massive premium but what would happen
is two years later all of a sudden those
policies would come off the books they'd
be sold to companies like mine that I
deal with and it was just it was a civil
war in the insurance industry there's no
question by the way a company called AXA
okay yeah I think it's called AXA think
I think it's called AA I mean obviously
I know what it's called but I think it's
called AXA but we have a meeting with
this man Tom you remember this meeting
we're on a boat somewhere in the world
we're on this boat I'm on a boat say
where it's at but it's a very cool place
but we're on a boat dep Maria and this
guy tells us that that company
went from 2003 selling 300,000 insurance
policies a year to less than 10 years
later selling only 50,000 because all
they focused on was these types of
policies and they said forget about
these smaller policies we're doing these
are a lot easier and they make us a lot
more money and then the company took a
big ass hit and they could no longer
turn back around to go back to the days
of doing 300,000 policies here because
that's very hard to do anyway and then
remember all the incentive trips all
these agents were going around the world
they're going all like they're going on
cruises they're making all this money
but I think at the end of the day much
like any get-rich quick scheme there's
always an unhappy ending there's only
one all these the only thought I'll give
you 30 seconds here I my dad told me
some advice years ago he says man should
not be in debt when man is in debt he
acts like a different man he doesn't
feel like a man it hurts your marriage
it hurts you as a man it hurts you as a
friend it hurts you as a as everything
that you do I'll give you three Deb
quotes okay here's one he who is quick
to borrow is slow to pay buy not pay
later it's a German proverb here's
another one for you if you think nobody
cares if you're alive try missing a
couple of car car payments that's Earl
Wilson here's another one for you from
Andrew Jackson is the best one when you
get in debt you become a slave yeah
these buying out pay lad companies are
simply enslaving millions of people and
I cannot stand it because I was a former
$49,000 of debt guy credit score 484 495
$499 don't fall for the 10 even in the
Bible it says that the borrower slave to
the lender so Adam with the Bible call
coming
in let's go to the next story just like
credit cards a consumer protection
agency is going to show up what's next
let's go to the next Story the next
story will go to is um do we want to do
John Stewart do we want to do uh uh
Rockets uh uh uh how about this to Bill
Mah Bill Mah says Trump is right that
schools teach kids to hate America
that's why them staffers are protesting
for Hamas here we go billar agrees at
Donald Trump that schools are currently
teaching children to hate America
stating that he's under uh he says under
his administration his next one schools
will teach students to love their
country not to hate their country like
they're taught right now I got to say
this one does doesn't bother me so I got
to say this one doesn't bother me so
much because I think that this is what I
see when I see kids demonstrating these
progressives uh demonstrating for Hamas
the most liberal people in the world
that oh good we're going to give America
its commant America this is the
this is uh uh this is they kind of have
been indoctrinated this way Mar
emphasized a generational split between
the Democratic party quoting the kids
seem to be with Palestinians and the
older generation seems to be with Israel
Vinnie what are your thoughts on this
story I dude just just I don't know Bill
Bill Maher to me is one of the most
flip-flopping I know Adam oh I know Adam
can't wait for you he's just he's he's
he's the prime example of trump
derangement syndrome that's all his
Network dude that's all Real Time with
Bill Mah was for four years was Trump
Trump trump all he pushed was the left's
agenda with Trump collusion Trump's an
agent you know vaccine he pushed all the
vaccines uh dude a I don't even think
he's that funny when when's the last
time you heard somebody go like this hey
guys you know what we saw we went to
last night and was hilarious Bill Maher
I mean who who's listening to an hour of
okay okay God doesn't exist okay it's
it's boring and just was this yesterday
Rob or a couple days ago he was he had
Roseanne on his couch of alcohol and I
don't know what the hell this podcast is
called weed lot of weed she goes she
asked him like she's like you got that
MK Ultra like thing he act he goes I
don't know what that is and then she
goes you know who CL Schwab he goes who
is that and then she goes he runs the WF
the this is the clip Pat is he like be
honest is he really this ignorant seen
it play
it I can't hear it Rob yeah I can't hear
any we can't hear
it you're on you the beginning Rob
thanks buddy no wonder I don't remember
this no you blocked it out MK Ultra
who's
that that's the mind control program
you're under Bill MK Ultra yeah so who's
but who's CLA Schwab the head of the
wef what's
that Google it he he really Pat that was
that's not like an act he acts like he
doesn't know who CL do you think he's
acting like he doesn't know or do you
think he knows but he knows 100% P he
knows CL he he is such a lukewarm
flip-flopping bro people like this
better hope and pray that Donald Trump
wins again so they have to talk
about I hate I hate some that one day
one day he's he hates them the other day
he's like oh I like what you think about
what he says here because he says you
know he says uh uh that schools are
teaching kids to hate America do you
agree with them on that I don't think I
don't think schools well which which
schools not the younger grade Public
Schools he's saying public schools are
teaching kids to hate America that's why
they're supporting pal you're saying yes
go ahead us go ahead well number one his
his uh podcast he does when he's not
doing Real Time with Bill Mah which is
on HBO and there's the after hours
that's picked up by CNN obviously he
used to be politically incorrect um it's
called Club random that's what he does
here with with Roseanne we had Roseanne
here what two months ago less than she's
let's just say adorably Alpha rockers
but that's another that's a different
point um Bill Maher um what I respect
about him and I would appreciate if
people on the left and on the right were
able to do what he's doing and what is
that he's actually calling out his own
side so there's no there's no secret
Bill Mah is a classic liberal he is not
one of these modern-day progressives and
even he says here there's a generational
split within the Democratic party
specifically we're seeing this over
Israel the kids seem to be with
Palestinians and Hamas whereas the older
generation seems to be with Israel
obviously he's an older guy he's
probably in his late 60s early 70s how
old is Bill but I would argue that he is
probably one of the most important
political voices in America today so yes
he does have some Trump 67 um yes he
does have some Trump derangement
syndrome I think anybody it's not once
you have it you have it I I'm seeing
some some uh cracks in the facade over
there where he's acknowledging Biden is
old as yeah and are we really going
to do this uh Dave Rubin was just on his
podcast did you see not his podcast
I think bill has done a good job this
year of calling out the left just as
much as they call out the right Tom he's
not a fan of the right what do you think
but he's clearly not a fan of the new
Left yeah Tom um this specific let me
read it again okay here's what he said
he said uh that under this
Administration kids are being taught to
hate America to hate their country do
you agree with that yes 100% And I I
applaud the fact that he saying these
things now if you back up and look at
Bill Mah and whole cloth over a two-e
period you'll see him say this on a show
this on the after hours this on Club
random okay fine there's some things
you're going to be upset about but I'm
backing up on it and I'm looking and I'm
seeing a guy who is starting to say
things and I appreciate the fact that
he's got the the the the the the stones
to do it he made a very important um uh
satirical point in an opening monologue
about the number of people per
generation % for Generation that were
identifying as trans or gay and he was
pointing out that hey something's wrong
here this is not it and he goes by this
math by 2050 we're all gay he pointed
that out and he was with facts and
figures I appreciate he did that and I
appreciated that he made the statement
because I think he's dead right we're
teaching kids to hate America and he's
correct you look at the college campuses
to take the Hamas position you know um
is not a you know a patriotic flag wve
being position I think he's right and I
applaud the fact that he's saying some
things now that show that he's turning
and to Adam's point he's picking not
picking on he's calling out his side do
you got do you think he's turning
because he's having this Epiphany Tom or
he knows that nobody wants to listen to
Just a trump hating loser people don't
no no hold on wa wait wait wait wait
wait wait stop right there not one of it
do you think any of his producers are
going to say let's move to the middle
because you're a trump hater do you
think anybody in mainstream media
there's not one person there unless they
are as stoned as he was right
there but more and more you're hearing
people like him going yeah but Trump was
right about this and Trump was right
about that and Trump was right but
meanwhile all the years of him pushing
that and dividing us I don't
forgive that easy all that Russia Russia
lying to everybody pushing the vaccine
pushing all this we're I I hate the fact
that Americans Pat just become now we're
just like oh whatever we're on to the
next thing no we got to hold people foot
to the fire all that that they push
all that hate it's it's no wonder why
people in the streets are and he's
talking about we're teaching kids how to
hate you taught Americans how to hate a
president that loved the country and now
oh now we're supposed to okay so what do
you do so what do you do I don't well
man up man up to it okay people that
could commit a crime can go to prison
but there's Chaplin in prison and they
can they can convert what if this guy is
having a slow move to he still show but
he still shows his colors Tom you still
talk about Trump he thinks Trump is
still he's still when he talked to Dave
ruin was like Trump and Russia no he was
involved it's like shut up with that
let he he's still stuck in that
world Tom he still believes everything
that Trump was was evil and negative and
World War II they pushed all that
Vinnie how soon you I'm not saying he
switch positions like how soon meaning
what okay so like since you've come here
you've obviously Gone full hard right
good for you you've embraced who you are
Define hard what's hard right right I'm
I'm just a conser I'm I'm a Conservative
Christian that was we didn't a year ago
you would have never said Conservative
Christian you mean you wouldn't even
said those words a Ser what do you mean
I I wasn't I haven't been a Christian
this whole time that I've been here sure
I don't think you would have vocalized
that as much as you are now you this
isn't this isn't a knock on you I'm
saying you found your position you found
your lane you're doubling down on it
amazing you're in that world now most
people don't change
positions quickly or even gradually most
people double down on their position
what I think Tom is trying to express is
that bill is a classic liberal just in
the mold of JFK or even a Bill Clinton
and what he's essentially calling out is
whatever this new liberalism or this new
Democratic party is it ain't your grand
papy's Democratic party so give him a
little grace to be like look a couple
years ago I didn't see this
thing coming and especially when Trump
was there it was so easy just double
down on Trump cool all good I'm not even
like if that's your thing it's that's
your thing but at least at this point
whether you like him or not acknowledge
that his positions are shifting and he's
calling out the people that need to be
calling out because everyone was calling
out the farri Maga extremists for years
now that has shifted to the far-left
woke progressives Hamas loving woke
agenda and give him credit for doing
that because he has the one is one of
the biggest bully pulpits on the left to
be like yo wake up yeah
cuz those are the people that are
watching his show show so in essence
what am I saying he's actually doing
more to help the cause you care about
than anyone on the far right okay any
let's go to the other way with that
let's go the other way a second the
Communists were criticized for referring
to Hollywood they had a phrase for him
what did they call them useful idiots
correct so you know what Kim did with
that clip that Bill Mar clip she
forwarded it to a bunch of other
teachers and people that she knew this
is the clip where he goes through transs
and he said I'm sitting here in Los
Angeles and it's almost fashionable to
say that your kids are having an ID
crisis fashionable and he called it out
Kim forwarded around a bunch of teachers
that said you know what I think he's
exactly right and I think it is
happening this way I think kids are
influencing kids I think kids that just
feel a little alone are are turning well
maybe I should be trans as a solution
and guess what that became useful it
became useful as a perspective saying
you know what maybe maybe there's
something to it I'm not talking about
kids that say I've always felt I was gay
B okay I'm talking about all this
confusion and sudden turning his
position is suddenly useful so useful
idiots can go both ways yeah let me say
one more thing I'm going to give you
give you the whole thing what I do agree
with what Tom was saying and I think is
essentially the question the pet asked
are they teaching kids to hate America I
don't know but what I do know is they're
not teaching kids to love America that's
a very good point that to me is the
biggest problem I don't know if they're
out there basically saying America sucks
don't but they're not standing up doing
the pled ofans they're not basically
learning how to basically say the Pledge
the national anthem to sing along to
basically be like country love your
country community service love America
the whole 1609 project or the black
national anthem we have one national
anthem in this country
National none of our founding fathers
given our Constitution are Patriots are
heroes I agree what's this patl owners
did you see her on C did you guys see
her on CNN yesterday I saw the I saw
have you seen this whole thing or did
you see whole she's a congresswoman Tom
have you seen this I have not seen this
okay first of I watch the whole thing
when you're when you're on there you
know uh uh what's her name what's the
other girl's name Dana Bash is it bash
something bash Dana Bash yeah she is
challenging her on her I'll just let her
play it has to do with Hamas yeah she is
she is look look what she says listen
other country I want to ask you about uh
sexual violence
and the it's kind of remarkable that
this issue hasn't gotten enough
attention uh globally widespread use of
rape uh brutal rape sexual violence
against isra women by Hamas um I've seen
a lot of progressive women generally
speaking they're quick to defend women's
rights and speak out against using rape
as a as a weapon of War but downright
silent on what we saw on October 7th and
what might be happening inside Gaza
right now to these hostages why is that
I I I mean I don't I don't know that
that's true I think we always talk about
the impact of War on women in particular
in fact I remember 20 years ago I did a
petition around the war in Iraq saying
have you talked about it since oober and
I've condemned what Hamas has done I've
condemned all of the actions absolutely
the the rape the of course but I think
we have to remember that Israel is a
democracy that is why they are a strong
Ally of ours and if they do not comply
with International humanitarian law they
are bringing themselves to a place that
makes it much more difficult
strategically for them to be able to
build the kinds of allies to keep public
opinion with them and frankly uh morally
I think we cannot say that one war crime
deserves another that is not what
international humanitarian law says with
respect I was just asking about the the
women and you turned it back to Israel
I'm asking you about Hamas in fact I
already answered your question Dana I I
said it's horrific and I think that rape
is horrific sexual assault is horrific I
think that it happens in War situations
terrorist organizations like Hamas
obviously are using these as tools
however I think we have to be balanced
about bringing in the outrages against
Palestinians 15,000 Palestinians have
been killed in Israeli air strikes
three4 of whom are women and children
it's horrible but you're you don't see
Israeli soldiers raping um well Dan
we're not we're not I I don't want this
to be the hierarchy of oppressions I
think 15,000 people have been killed
palan 2.2 million Palestinians live in
140 square mile area which is about the
size of Las Vegas with a population that
is 4 times that of Las Vegas and and 1.8
million Palestinians right now are
displaced they are living in shelters
they are being told to move to South
Gaza then South Gaza is being bombed
they're being told to move
you pause it right there what do you
think about this when you hear this Tom
uh I I I think the progressive side has
kind of lost its moral mind I I have a
listening to that and I'm trying to find
what compass and what position she's
she's coming from she's ignoring how
this whole thing started she's ignoring
the the carefully made point at the end
the Israelis are not committing
atrocities against the prisoners and
citizenry and I think that's the core
Point here is who started it and you
have an in just a
ridiculously evil side of it that
perpetrated these things they are the
Invaders they did it well you were our
oppressors we invaded to defend yeah but
not like that and I have a hard time
with that moral compass I mean how do
you make that argument in your mind to
start with the Hamas Invasion and the
rapes and the the atrocities that
happened and things that were not were
not guessing this isn't reuter's
guessing people have been released
hostages have been released and they're
and they're they're talking and they're
talking about things and with remarkable
consistency then you come to the other
side and and you just want to turn it
into you know well Israel's bombing
civilians you you there there are two
issues there are to be discussed but I I
have how does I have a hard time with
her moral compass and she's chairman of
the progressive caucus so she's bought
and paid for she can't take any other
possession Vinnie what do you think
about what she said
I I think a they they'll never answer
never answer you know politicians are
she'll never answer an honest question
she was she was one of the biggest
voices against Brett Kavanagh like just
all in on him being rape even though he
had all the proof and all the thing from
the childhood is just not being able to
just answer the questions like listen
raping hostages you if you can't
verbally just say that out loud and your
answer is well you know Israel does bad
things too I think it's horrific I think
she I think I'm I don't even like the
girl in the right was it bash but to put
her on blast like that it's good I think
that that type of reporting we need more
of P putting putting them on putting her
foot to the fire well look anytime
there's any sort of War you know
innocent victims are going to die that's
just the unfortunate sight of War I wish
you know if we could all do some sort of
Kumbaya moment and there would be no war
in this world and peace on Earth
unfortunately humans are very flawed and
that is just part of our DNA uh and it's
call it tribalism call it nationalism
this is the world we live in and it's
the world will continue to live in but
the moral equivocation between actual
terrorists and a democratic Ally of the
United States is unfathomable to me and
especially you're seeing this pop up on
the Progressive leftist Wing if anything
I'm seeing this play out America is
seeing this play out and when we were at
the Republican debates I mean it kind of
seemed like an Israel rally at the
Republican debates different areas in in
Miami I would say yes uh in in La partly
yeah but but that La was prior to
October 7th so I mean it was it was sort
of just for sure it was it was yeah it
was like even as I'm Jewish I'm like
guys let's take it down a little bit
Yeah but it's it's good to see the
Republican Party stands with their
allies to me as an American as a proud
American who does have roots in Israel
I'm an American first guy I understand
where I that where is US lie with this
where's United States allies just look
at the map who are the allies of Hamas
who funds haras Hamas just look at the
map it's Iran who's Iran funding
Hezbollah terrorist organization Hamas
terrorist organization houthi rebels in
Yemen terrorist organization by the way
that just fired on United States ships
in the Middle East okay again firing on
our people okay who's funding all this
nonsense China who's who's over there in
that world North Korea Russia Iran so
obviously Iran at the at the tip of the
spear here so I align with the United
States allies so that's why when I see
new leaders pop up like our muddy mle in
Argentina who says I will not deal with
Communism and what we're starting to see
is the Communists on the far left and
the autocrats on the far right
coalescing at the very bottom of this
horseshoe that it makes no freaking
sense that far-left Progressive Liberals
are identifying with the most illiberal
people in the world which is Hamas it
makes no sense to me so to answer your
question it is
unfathomable what's happening here and
that's why we're just looking for basic
common sense you've heard me use my the
lens I look through I said if you want
to see what's going on Downstream you
got to go Upstream to see what caused it
and because we have Upstream problems
and downstream problems you know it's a
it's a classic thing you have a polluted
lake and the Liberals want to build a 10
trillion dollar filter conservatives
want to go upstream and say why is that
factory putting pesticides in the river
that made the lake just stop the factory
and so where's the factory
yesterday Bill Amman had a long tweet on
X about his letter back to the president
of Harvard along with the data that he
got from surveying people it was a long
letter back and this was Bill Amman back
to Harvard dear president gay and it was
huge and he went through here about free
speech about what the about what even
moderate professors are finding it was
thing you go Upstream that's what's
happening all you have to do is go up to
Harvard and look at it and it makes Bill
Mah's point they're being taught to hate
America so when they're taught to hate
America they're taught that there's no
sense of patriotism or and there and and
that they all that moral relativism and
that's all she's doing is showing that
her church is a church of moral
relativism and she's being interviewed
by Dana Bash that's it but where does it
come from you go upstream and you find
it you find out what's happening in
colleges you find out how they're being
taught and not taught that's it and you
see what's going on it doesn't surprise
me now and you see what's going on
around the world like you see what
turkey's erdogan had to say he's
basically calling Israel um war
criminals calling uh Netanyahu war
criminals really erdogan are your hands
clean no not is the Ottoman Empire and
turkey's hand clean let's ask some
Armenian friends of ours if you're the
moral Authority on all this kind of
stuff because be careful who you start
calling out be careful who you align
with this guy is supposed to be a NATO
Ally aligning with the United States but
he is flip-flopping so it's just where
where were all the people when Syria
when Bashar al- Assad started killing
all his people where were the
Palestinian Marchers where was the
Palestinian Brigade marching on behalf
of Arabs who are being murdered okay in
Afghanistan when the Taliban is raping
women and doing whatever they want with
women where's the Palestinian Brigade
and the gazen Brigade and the woke mob
for that but only when Israel wants to
defend himself that's when you can speak
up so the like do it all the time and
then we'll believe
but obviously this comes down to
anti-semitic Jew hate and that's what
this basically is at the end of the day
okay let's go to the next story here K
more retired Americans are un retiring
and many worry about age discrimination
okay
interesting so a Resume Builder survey
found that 12% of uh currently retired
Americans expect to return to work in
2024 with reasons including inflation
and a higher cost of living and
combating boredom as stated in the
survey a significant concern among these
retirees is age bu with two-thirds of
those expecting to reenter the workforce
next year expressing fear that it'll
affect their job prospects career coach
Stacy holler the chief career adviser at
Resume Builder emphasize the importance
of modernizing resumés don't use an AOL
email address don't put your street
address on a resume pictures don't
belong on a resume she suggests focused
on the past 15 years of experience as
talking about exactly what you did that
long long ago really won't help you get
a job today Satan what do you think
about the story of un
retiring so it's very interesting we
live in South Florida and you can find
two types of retirees down here retirees
that are commuting back and forth from
the north they call them snowbirds and
they're part-time they have maybe a
small condo down here they were able to
buy that and they come down here when
the weather is warm in the winter so the
rheumatism and arthritis isn't so bad
and then you have the people that are
living here full-time we have come Kim
and I have become acquainted with some
people full-time and so this is me and
my bubble and my little perspective but
what's interesting is where are we
encountering them we're encountering
them at business that we patronize and
we're seeing them and there's a business
we patronize on weekends uh I'm not not
going to name it um that uh is in in
service business and we see the same
folks there every weekend and I ask them
how you doing I'm doing great I'm doing
this and what do you do well I do this
because number one I stay active and
number two you know on Social Security
and my pension I don't get a inflation
adjustment they said exactly what's in
this article I don't get this so guess
what I I interesting I see people like
you you're very nice to us all the time
I get to talk to people I stay active
and it's an easy and it's not a hard job
but it's a necessary job that they're
doing they're not washing dishes and so
they're coming out to do it so part of
it I think it's good that they stay
active I just think I think it's bad
that they thought that they had
retirement figured out and now they feel
forced back out to do it that can't be a
good feeling you know what be even worse
how about going to an unretirement party
just standing around you're like hey
John you're like just have another shot
you we're this sucks it's like a
divorce party it's like a div yeah he's
just hanging out like they put the gold
watch Back In The Box on the show yeah
and he's like listen on top of the money
he's like my wife is just a pain in the
ass I got to get out of the house that
would suck dude but that's hey and it
cuz they said boredom in there too right
people just broke well this this just
sort of is a a great glimpse into the
current state of the American retirement
system because Social Security was never
meant to be a retirement program okay
and a lot of Americans just as Susie
Orman kind of reference we can even
bring that thing up where she says the
government's not coming to save you or
Susie Orman who is a financial expert if
you're not familiar with her she warns
of the looming Financial pandemic she
basically Ed some sort of um metaphoric
U Financial pandemic response right
there but the reality is there's nothing
sadder to see a 74 yearold woman who's
saying yeah I'm running out of money I
need to go back to work while she's
submitting her resume with AOL email
address her home address come on by lady
so that is so sad to me and I see these
people all the time like my mom's still
working my mom has zero Hobbies so I
want her to continue working by the way
for any of our friends out there whose
parents are considering retiring unless
they actually have hobbies just keep
working guys because life expectancy in
this country I know it has gone down a
little bit during the pandemic but
people are living longer than ever yeah
10 years if you retire 10 years younger
you die quicker than working 10 years
longer stay active stay busy Stay Stay
um stay motivated keep your brain going
this is why Charlie moner and even
Warren Buffett are going to even Henry
kisser last to 100 you got to keep your
mind going but there's nothing sadder to
see me getting you know I Uber
everywhere there's nothing sadder to go
see a 78-year-old Uber driver show up
and I'm like what's up man he's like oh
you know uh just you know got back to
driving Uber and me I'll talk to these
guys and I was like well why you you're
driving Uber because occasionally you
get the guy like you said that's like I
just got to get out of the house my wife
wife but occasionally you'll get the guy
who's like and I had a real conversation
with a guy he's like yeah I just never
learned how to save I made a lot of
money I was in the fashion industry some
78-year-old guy driving Uber and
I'm like man he goes do you mind leaving
an extra tip I tipped him an extra 20 he
say that I swear to God he did oh wow I
swear he like you could tell he has a
pitch like it wasn't like he was like
hey he's like hey you know times are
tough and I'm working here at 78 and I
had to get back to Uber I used to be in
the fashion industry he had a whole
Spiel he had a whole pitch and he's like
so if you don't mind tipping more than
you typically do upselling he might be
full of though at the same time I
was like you know might be his pit but
if you're driving Uber that script I
respect it if you're driver right now
use it yeah but no listen life is about
this goes back to the concert uh uh CAC
took me which was you know at a time
where I had lost my voice I went through
a surgery and I couldn't speak for a
couple months uh and we go to this
concert darush is singing Dar darush
he's singing and he gets up who's that
is that like the Timberlake Michaels
no not a Michael who would be like a
Persian Kenny G not Kenny G what's the
lady who's Lady the the lady Lady Kenny
Roger she like a Persian Kenny Roger
okay so very famous and he birday
February 4th you know he's a great man I
don't like him anymore I hate that guy
he Ubers the guy definitely
Ubers you know what I used to like you
daru Dar anyway so he says something at
this event he says look first of all
want to apologize for not coming to many
of your weddings it says because I never
sang Happy songs why would you invite me
to your wedding my songs are sad songs
he says so I apologize he's just flat
out apology it was such an interesting
moment he says but I like to take a
moment to talk to the people that are
younger 20s 30s and 40s that's the way
he puts it he says make sure the young
wolf in you takes care of the old wolf
you'll one day be you're going to be an
old wolf the other in other words use
the five you have when you're young to
save invest take care of your health
make the right Investments be in the
right environment have the right friends
be friend the right people run with the
right folks you know pay attention to
the things that matter the most because
one day you're going to wake up you're
going to be like I'm 70 freak the other
day I'm talk I'm on I'm on the nek boy
podcast uh fulls podcast and I'm talk I
really like talking to these guys and
we're having a good time and I say how
old are you and he says I'm 28 how old
are you I'm 29 I'm sinner saying
you're freaking 45 years old man I mean
you know 45 is Young don't get me wrong
but Vinnie 45 is 45 right talking to a
28-year old no no what I'm saying is
like and then and then I'm telling a
story about the fact I remember 15 years
ago when I was in the Army I'm like dude
15 years ago you started a company you
were you were in the Army 27 years ago
that doesn't make any sense to me crazy
I don't know if you understand like he
just went somewhere right now focus on
Adam's
face I just I just blacked out for a
second what yeah I'm just happy he
called 40 young the the point is welcome
back yeah the point is this thing goes
by real quick bro this thing goes by
real quick I'm having conversations with
my oldest son that are just two serious
conversations that I'm not used to
having these step yeah we've always had
great conversations but it's getting
more and more serious and he's 11 in
about 10 years this guy's going to be 21
years old like this do you remember when
you do you remember when you were 11 and
you talk to like somebody Uncle whoever
and they're like yeah I'm 45 you're like
oh my God you're going to die soon would
I'd be like oh my God hey kids if you
guys ever watch this one day just want
to give you guys a shout out you never
made me feel old at this age you're very
nice to me 1110 72 when I ask you guys
hey how old is old so Daddy you're not
old you're 45 you're young they still
tell me what do they what do they say
about Papa they say they say 80 years
old yeah they say 80 years old I said
okay fair enough so they think Papa's
old and Dylan likes to make fun of the
way Papa walks and he does such a good
job oh my I got he goes like
this I got to see
this because it's true it's true that
how Papa Gabriel walks well that's so
that is the Walk of regalness I mean the
regalness the guy's back regalness he's
like Regal Like an Eagle he walks
like but anyways so listen unretired
folks uh respect you guys for not making
any excuses on getting to work and at
the same time some of you are doing it
because you're bored uh for all the
younger folks uh make sure the you know
young wolf in you takes care of the old
wolf one day you'll be next story want
to get into do you want to get into
Trump Cola DeNiro or coach udoka against
LeBron which one you want to go you pick
both both both both incident you want to
go to the coach let's go to the coach
the Rockets coach IM Uka ejected after
altercation of LeBron James
okay uh this is a outkick story the Los
Angeles Lakers defeated the Houston
Rockets 10797 but the highlight of the
game was an altercation between Rockets
coach yoka and LeBron James leading to
Yoda's ejection udoka mentioned we had
some conversations and they didn't like
what they heard udoka expressed
frustration with the game and criticized
the Lakers physicality saying to kind of
get punked by a team that's not known
for physicality or punking people is not
a good sign LeBron James downplay the
incident joking that he and udoka were
discussing their enjoyment of
Thanksgiving the history between udoka
and James who faced each other as
players over a decade ago was noted and
the upcoming game between the Rockets
and the Lakers on January 29th was
mentioned by the way this is what was
said okay Adam you follow this story
closely do you have the exact script
because the video is everywhere okay and
you can hear him you've seen the video I
you sent it to me yeah so if you go to
it I just want to see the words man if
you can find the words that they have it
in there you had one of them just go
back to what you had yeah kind of goes
back and saying you know y'all stop
crying like little man ok is
promoting his first response to j s
we're all grown men and James said that
wart ain't cool man he says you
you throw that Ward around too Loosely
he said what are you going to do about
it so what he do about to his face
anyways obviously nothing happened but
you could tell coach was ready to throw
down Adam your thoughts on well you know
who this guy is IM yoka right because
everybody on this listen to the podcast
knows who LeBron James is okay yeah but
there's more to it you know he was the
you Boston okay so the ironic thing that
LeBron who for all intents and purposes
actually is a good family man he'll go
down inarguably as the second greatest
basketball player of all time father
husband NBA legend he's arguing with a
guy named e oku now most people are
goingon to be listen obviously we have a
huge Sports audience here that's just
basically loving the segment but
basically oku you know who he coached
before the Houston Rockets the Boston
Celtics now why did he get fired from
the Boston Celtics because he wasn't
taking LeBron's advice cuz he was
all the in Boston that
worked for the Celtics and they got
fired literally that's what they were
arguing about stop using the b word stop
saying cuz he basically just for
you know disclaimer purposes they were
arguing did were we able to play the
clip or no they were basically arguing
over he's like y'all playing like
and LeBron basically said yo
stop using that word and he's like n
y'all are he's like no seriously
like not cool and you can tell that it
got under LeBron's skin for whatever
reason and truth be told I try to stop
using b word as well but for this story
I will but he started egging LeBron on
but again we talk about moral High
ground and moral Clarity both lack some
of that LeBron politically eay literally
so it's interesting to see that these
two were going back over this
situation finny any thoughts on this I
you know what that I'm so happy now that
I used to be a crazy by the way I'm I'm
still a huge Yankee fan I'm a giant I I
can care about the records or whatever
cuz we've won a lot but not caring about
about sports anymore is one of the most
like
liberating no P can I be honest with you
like I freaking love it besides ad Adam
thinks I went all the way right even
though I've been thinking like this
since I was in Los Angeles okay but you
admit you're far right no no I don't
think I'm far right it took you know
what and I'm being genuine and and I'm
going to be completely honest with all
you guys I didn't I swear to God I
didn't know what left or right or
anything was until Donald Trump won and
then I went whoa what the hell is going
on and I saw exactly what the hell was
going on and I went you know what that's
the swamp that those are the people that
hate us then call me whatever the hell
you want I'm the opposite of that that's
fine but back it's very liberating now
by the way LeBron like you're a
basketball I think Sports has gotten way
too soft you remember back in the day in
basketball games everybody was calling
everybody a they were talking they
your mother bad boys of the 80s Isaiah
vers MJ nobody what happened when they
were beating up the fans uh was it the
the Detroit W world peace they were
beating the
test really you're they're whooping Fest
was kicking people in the face I think
that's where they really implemented
their social justice campaign they we're
like all right it's okay to beat each
other's ass when you go into the crowd
some white kid in the crowd he throw but
just yeah there it was you just had it
right there can't show it relax but just
just in general we have him Sports p
with football and the kickoffs every
everything's got soft you can't talk to
him like I don't respect
athleticism yeah but LeBron I had
experience with LeBron in Los Angeles uh
a little I was with a guy that's family
is extremely wealthy and we're all at
expens expensive place in Beverly Hills
and a little kid that we didn't know was
like Hey LeBron signature he's like man
like brushed them off the Securities
being a jerk my friend walked over there
and yelled at LeBron James like a kid
he's like who the do you think you are
this is in Toronto he goes who the
you think you are you're all big and bad
he goes a little kid wants an autograph
you're not going to get like I don't
respect him on that I don't respect him
on China but it's so liberating Pat so
let me guess LeBron slapped him
using the b word LeBron no yeah he went
like this he went be slapped him but he
signed it but just just I I I've I'm so
I feel so good now like on Sunday
besides going to church and stuff I'm
not sitting there yelling yelling at
another stranger because his guy his
team of strangers that are wearing
tights are doing better than my team of
guys in tight I'll tell you why I agree
with you so much on this on this
specific point one of the biggest things
that changed the trajectory of my life
no joke was taking my Sundays back
because I when I was in my mid 20s just
like a lot of young 20s you know you're
in three fantasy football leagues I'm
rooting for the Dolphins it's Sunday
then it's Monday Night Football now they
get Thursday Night Football then in the
playoffs it's Saturday and it's Sundays
and then you're watching your teams
you're in three leagues and each player
is competing against I said this is nuto
and I went cold turkey I stopped doing
all fantasy football whatsoever and I
freed up my entire son day that was in
2015 and what did I start doing in 2015
creating social media content streamline
that right here to hang with you guys
you want Pat I agree 100% if doesn't it
feel good I'm going to send I sent rob a
photo this is me in LA Los Angeles uh in
Hollywood the Giants are they just beat
the 49ers I'm about to beat the out
of everybody look at look where I am I'm
in La I'm standing up with the white
shirt I'm about by the way that's
security Vin you're you're 5'8 on a good
day so you're standing on
he's the same height as I'm standing on
there s yeah you know what Adam yeah
what if I was like what are you talking
about Adam that's a Ron off his
boots but that's me it's it's a great
feel like I love like P we go to a game
and I a video no it's just a photo of by
the way there's only one Giants fan in
the back that's me that's when we when
uh they fumbled the the return we won
the Super Bowl this year bro I that guy
wanted beat in the play you going to
fight 49ers f i this every you actually
did fight this is when the ner punt
returner fumbled twice fumbled twice
that there's only one New Yorker in the
back I had to fight not this guy the guy
in front of him outside it's like what
we for changing your life I I
tried we just talked about that you have
changed for the better CH 100% okay so
like that's me back in the day beating
the out of people for no reason the
young Vinnie I was young wolf will thank
the I was a longtime Laker fan going
back to the the days the 20s with George
Mikey ex exactly right the where they
actually black and white black and white
videos when when they invented the saw
to cut down the trees to make the
hardwood floor I was there when Dr Smith
you know yeah you were the Marty McFly
to uh Dr Brown Dr N I know look at
LeBron this guy is soft the most points
NBA history most uncalled traveling
fouls in history most flops in history
he's in the record books forever right
when Michael Jordan went to the Major
League Baseball do you know about the
trash talking that he got Major League
Baseball he got a walk and you know what
they used to say to him they used to
poke him they used to say things well if
you can't hit it every now and then you
get the first base anyway they would say
things like this to him because he was
coming over and and they would say
things like you know harder than it
looks isn't it yeah yeah you know we're
not athletes are we then they would poke
it was all in good fun but the point
they would poke but if you've ever seen
a Major League umpire come out and talk
to the UMP oh oh no no the UMP will
discover his parents weren't married
when he was born there was a whole lot
of things especially this ump that uh
was about to retire he's got a
reputation the one that re correct he
was feared and there is an ump that
comes back at it and it's like exactly
and so LeBron's having this like quiet
conversation in the NBA they called the
technical then they ejected right he
went technical Technical and then he
ejected I look at it I don't like that
product that's why I don't like the NBA
as a product right now I'm a diard Laker
fan going back to worthy and AC Green
that was when I my my love for the NBA
and the Lakers was born at those times
and Magic Tom and Magic Showtime magic I
I'll add one more thing to you by the
way Once Upon a Time if you're a Laker
fan we called it the norm Nixon trade
and we were all upset about it a year
later we called it the Byron Scott deal
because we traded Norm Nixon for Byron
Scott oh you really went like I mean
yeah you layered it Tom I respect James
Worthy Magic Johnson we get when you get
into SC
8788 back to back what I will say is
just not a good product and I think this
is so soft if you're going to get
ejected get ejected for something this
is so soft Tom the irony of Tom the bis
do who was the smartest guy I know
calling LeBron James arguably the
greatest athlete ever soft is hilarious
call him a a we won't do I
gave him credit for the most called Trel
his that most people I thought he was
singing when he said once upon a time in
94 monel made the money of life I
thought he was
singing time
but one thing I will add and and and to
to create to compare anybody to MJ is
probably unfair the guy was just
ridiculous a man amongst men but one
thing that they did not have in MJ's day
when he was playing basketball or even
baseball was social media this was not
picked up by TNT it was picked up by
someone's phone recording it so there's
all a lot of C citizen journalism going
on there so I'm wondering what kind of
would have been picked up back in
the day now everything's picked up Tik
Tok every but Westbrook is making it
West
kick him out kick him out out I don't
want to get go rers in New York and see
what happens to your ass all right let's
go to a different story let's go to a
different story where actually shit's
being talked and we they they both like
it okay Trump flips out at Bob Bobby
dairo flips out at Bobby DeNiro uh
former president Donald Trump on Sunday
issued a belated unhinged response to
actor this is a huff pole by the way
when they use the word unhinged to actor
Robert din's Fierce criticism of him
last week's Gotham award ceremony Trump
hit back on his Tru social platform at
the weekend calling Deno a total loser
Robert Deno Who acting talents have
greatly diminished with his reputation
now Shad must even a teleprompter for
his foul and disgusting language so dis
disrespectful to our country Ro Trump he
has become unwatchable both in movies
and with the fools that destroyed the
Academy Awards bringing them from one of
the top shows in the country to a
low-rated afterthought uh dairo show
should focus on his life which is a mess
rather than the lives of others he has
become a total loser as the world
watches Waits and laugh how long you
been working on that uh Trump impression
that was perfect but you know what guess
what nothing like be honest does
anything about that bother you and and
here is the here is the history of
Donald Trump and the media and people
and you can talk to him you can go
at him but the moment he responds he's
unhinged he's whatever that's why he's
going to go down as one of the dopest
presents cuz he doesn't give a he
wears his heart and his sleeve by the
way who who went after who first Robert
dairo called him a dog remember he
called him this he called them that good
for you bro that's a New Yorker talking
back to another New Yorker you talk
to me I'm going to talk back
to you I do think it's hilarious cuz by
by the way let's follow along
unwatchable movies I agree you can't
like good dude Good Fellas and all those
movies you can't compare them to what
the hell he's doing now uh destroy the
Academy Awards fact uh top shows in the
country low rated fact you know I mean I
don't he's to focus on his life he did
get divorced and everything but bro if
you talk you got to be able to get
it back Robert dairo talks and he
gets talk back good for him good
for Trump I think Trump should just make
a rule because obviously it's no secret
Trump will go hit back at anybody good
okay Rosie O'Donnell Megan Kelly dairo
Trump if you hear me out here brother
stick to the a-listers you can go after
the a-listers Bob is a a-lister that's
my point you want to go after the dairos
of the world or the scorsis of the world
or the porcinos of the world or leading
of Decap cool when you start going after
like Chachi from Good Times And
basically like go after no just any
random people you want to start going
after uh Arnold from The Facts of Life
or Different Strokes it's like how low
are you going to go here because you
know keep it to A-list and above no Bist
actors certainly don't hit after some
random obscure hey Seth Green got a
message for you Adam do you respect do
you Adam but do you respect the fact
that he's going after people that are
literally going after him you you you're
poking the we know about every
single president ever in the history of
America is they wouldn't address any
attacks from random citizens there
social media there no social media
correct even if they were famous
a-listers he's a he Loser yeah Trump let
me ask would you rather have him do a
Kevin Durant and get a burner account
okay and you know act like other people
are saying it like just like the left us
all the time those guys those guys are
famous for burner accounts or would you
rather have a guy that doesn't use a
burner account he uses his account which
would you prefer I'm not even going in
the hypotheticals meaning I'm addressing
that he is doing it it is coming from
him and it is what it is so what we're
saying is whether you're comfortable
with it or whether you're not Trump's
going to do it my my the 59 people
places and things he this is my point I
guarantee if we go this list we can pick
10% that's like cool go after Bob diro
cool go after Martin scor Cas these are
no
names dog
dog di like a dog a beautiful dogful dog
they didn't even knock normally you
would knock in the door hey can I come
in no they didn't do it they didn't do
that the the limit the the lipis test
should be whoopy Goldberg or above but
yeah that's like an A minus view
celebrity or a good point but if you go
down this list and you start hey um Al
hey I remember the actor from Al
back like really bro you w really going
but if you think about Forget by the way
do you realize do you realize if this
guy wins this is coming for that's what
I want it's been boring by the way do
you realize press conferences do you
realize messaging do you realize sit
down sit down sit down your show sucks
anyways you're
and that's what well by the way that's
America and you know when people say we
want a a president for the People by the
people that's Americans he's the average
American talking trolling attitude
onlinein Vin wait Vin Donald Trump is
not the average American meaning meaning
his he not whatever you're about to say
he is not the average American he's a
billionaire buildings all he knows the
price of milk he goes to he goes to he
eats McDonald public in Palm Beach every
and down the street you think president
Trump makes his own peanut butter and
jelly sandwich in
morning the
a what I'm saying
is the Aver what what I'm what I mean is
Adam the this trolling this internet
this talking that's what Americans
do go pretty sad listen I love it
let's go to the next story let's go to
the next story so Tucker Carlson drops
bombshell revealing what got him fired
with Fox News uh let's see what the
reason is for him getting fired so T
Caron former Fox News host uh discuss
his departure from the network stating I
didn't expect to get you know my show
cancelled Monday morning expressing his
lack of surprise but not providing
specific reasons for the firing he added
they were very nice to me the entire
time I was there but I could feel that
they strongly disagreed in the war in
Ukraine stuff they really didn't like
that at all the January 6 stuff Carlson
also hinted at unpredictably of the the
upcoming 2024 presidential election
noting that it might not be a con
contest between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump due to establishment's actions and
Biden's declining popularity in the poll
saying this is not going to be a race
between Joe Biden and Trump and by the
way Rob right before this gave me some
news Rob did you did you see that story
with uh now they're going after Justin
Wills uh his business part and according
to Wall Street Journal Tucker Carlson's
longtime producer is accused of sexual
assault in suit former Fox News staffer
said Justin Wells forcibly kissed him
and grabbed his grabed his genitals what
in late 2008 Wells denied the Alle so I
had I didn't even know he was gay man on
man stuff who who's this guy so he the
to talk Justin wells in a lawsuit from
former Fox News Dan Justin Wells invited
him to go come to his bar before they
were uh join other people at nearby bar
the alleged incent took place in 2000
shortly after join St the suit set so
after serving him a drink Wells pushed n
to his bed forcibly kissed him and
grabbed his genitors the L alleged full
lawsuit which was filed in New York
Monday here we go again that sounds like
a Thursday night Adam that's a Thursday
night F that's a guy doing it to another
guy that's just classic locker room buy
like slaps my ass every time I see every
single time hey
tip check that's how we roll bro that's
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question how much of this how how much
of this do you think it's you know Fox
finding ways to get back at Tucker and
how much of this you think it's real
what what do you think this it's all
going after to talk think it's a
combination anything to discredit him
because yeah go ahead I think it's a
combination of number
one they were on the clock because they
had to get these suits filed and number
two I think fox look do they leak things
about their talent when they're
negotiating new contracts they do do
they leak things about their talent when
they leave and go to another place well
he was a handful to work with and the
ratings were slipping according to ourl
analysis when someone leaves and goes
from let remember Katie krik left and
she went to Yahoo and all of a sudden
NBC was like well it all wasn't what you
really think it was and they leak those
things out did they do that yes they do
so as Fox leaking right now yes but is
there already these um um Adam what is a
deadline there was a deadline a week ago
for the harassment suits you could go
back you could go back 25 years why do
you think I know that dat yeah no no you
were right Tom you're actually you're
absolutely right it was like a I forgot
the name of it but they I looked around
the I was just going to ask you that
question sexual assaults no I was going
to go to Wikipedia or you and I went to
you so this is what it's called right
here that's why that's why Diddy got is
the complaint said it fell under the
adult Survivor act a law that passed in
New York's Democratic leg legislature
and took effect on Thanksgiving last
year that law opened a yearlong window
during which people who say they were
sexually assaulted as adults could sue
their alleg abusers regardless of when
the alleged abuse
occurred you see come out from
the 80s and I think Fox absolutely said
hey that guy's filing a suit and then
they throw a leak out to page six well
and dude and look how easy this is I
know you were joking at him you know how
easy it is to do the sexual assult like
ready for this Adam yesterday in the in
the break room you grabbed my crotch
that's it it's a story it's out anything
Vinnie but that's whatever you know why
because I was in the
sauna I hate when he brings but but but
B all it is is an accusation and by the
way there's no cameras in there you talk
prove me wrong but now it's in the news
it's you have to get a lawyer and then
it's and now people think you back to
the actual Tucker situation right cuz
we're talking about his producers we're
talking about whoever the guy was back
to the Tucker situation this article
which is basically from what the daily
fetched whatever which one are you
talking about what the one you just read
Tucker the one I
talked the the Justin Wells is from Wall
Street Journal no no not that one this
yes regardless the real reason that
regard me go ahead what were we going to
say just hit this nail on the head Adam
if you're going to Jes but the point is
what this article leaves out are two
major names they don't talk about the
murdocks yeah and they don't talk about
Roger alses and they certainly don't
talk about Dominion to me that's the
three biggest reasons that Tucker got
fired they're sort of subjugating it
with this uh Ukraine stuff January 6
whatever Roger ales died the murdocks
and the Murdo kids took over Dominion
what was it $1.8 billion lawsuit what
was it maybe even more big whatever the
hell it was and I assume part of the
lawsuit was they needed a head to roll
and who's a bigger head literally Fox
News nailing him in the head right
there Then Tucker Carlson so that's to
me the reason that he basically left if
the murdocks wanted Tucker there he
would still be there but they they
didn't choose a good enemy pack cuz he
chose his enemy why if you think about
it he chose them and he went hit that
nail I hit that nail on the head
speaking of I mean not not to be the B
but hey Vinnie not to cut you off but go
ahead
Tom Right Tom goad your Point's more
important um and what bugs me about this
story is repeatedly grabbed repeatedly
grabbed his apartment if you're going to
grab it Tom you're going to go for at
his apartment at his apartment Dr it so
number one you're at the apartment
number two after after a grab you'd be
like dude you're drunk get away from me
and and then a second attempt don't you
leave but you're hanging around for
repeatedly grab it's like the old it's
it's it's it's you're hanging around for
another grab that's right playing grab
ass it's like the old mon python film
that goes you were raped and he says
well at
first it's start by by the way you know
it it I I I've spoken to Justin before
he's very respectful when he and I my
experience with him has been great but
this is even a bigger thing to show that
Tucker no matter what his position is
his main executive his main producer is
gay and Tucker never talked about it he
didn't use that adverti it anything
again we find out in a situation like
this if it wasn't for the grabbing we
would have never known okay nobody cares
everything in this story is allegedly we
don't know who's grabbing and touching
and playing grab us other than me
grabbing Vinnie in the break room I am a
little bit uncomfortable when these
stories come out like this yeah whenever
it comes out like this kind of pump the
brakes and put a little bit of the
paranoid hat on and see what's going on
so Derek shovin okay oh man is
discharged from hospital after being
stabbed
22 times uh uh in in uh uh in jail the
former Minneapolis cop senten to 22
years from George Floyd's murder has
been discharged from the hospital after
being stabbed 22 times in prison by John
turac a career criminal and is now back
at Federal Correctional Institution in
Tucson Arizona according to reports John
Tac turac
who used an impr impro improvised knife
to attack chovin in the prison library
on Black Friday has been charged like
you had to put Black Friday there has
been charged with attempted murder and
revealed that he has been planning the
attack for month due to Shin's
high-profile status Tac indicated that
he chose Black Friday because of its
connection to the black lives matter
movement sparked by Floyd's murder Tom
you see to have a reaction to it what
are your thoughts on the story I'm
trying to figure out how Black Friday
shopping day which was named back in the
80s or earlier I'm trying to figure out
how that is somehow connected to watch
the language Tom watch it to to BLM
outside of one word happens to be the
same that's confusing me and the other
thing is you know it sounds like Derek
Chavin is lucky to be alive stabbed 22
times how do you select 22 places to get
stabbed in some somehow not bleed out or
well I mean well let's let's really
clear he bought the knife on Black
Friday it wasn't sharp enough he got a
good deal it's a makeshift shiv or
whatever you want to call it but the the
which is usually a sharpened toothbrush
by the way they take plastic toothbrush
Tom you would know cuz you remember that
time you did that stint in s Quin I feel
like Tom would be a great uh recurring
character Will Ferrell's movie Tom would
be Tom would be the Walter White
murdering Tom would be that guy but uh
my name is Heisenberg yeah but but you
would be a great sidekick I feel
like we we're actually writing a script
but if you think about it this can you
be Jesse Yeah there's Tom right here
yeah
um up y'all hey get get hard homie I'm a
doctor of business but Rob wasn't that
true but pad that was the the week he
got stabbed there was the report that
was released because of that girl about
the the the uh Coroner's report of how
uh what's his name uh George Floyd was
actually killed where there was
questioning Pat that the Fentanyl and it
wasn't the actual exfix so the timing
was weird that the week that he was
trying to appeal his case uh a guy that
was is an FBI informant or used to be
against I think I guess the Mexican uh
gangs he's he stabs this guy 22 times
and doesn't do the job and by way it
wasn't just an appeal this was a this
was a a RIT that was put before The
Supreme Court for
reconsideration trying to get to the US
Supreme Court that the US solicitor
general refused to even hear so the
solicitor general is like the uh it's
like the guy at the Velvet Rope if you
think of the Supreme Court as a club and
the guy at the ropes got to let you in
solicit general we don't even by the way
you know how committed this guy was to
this crime to killing Derrick schin
trying to he's his nickname is read this
his nickname is stranger he's been
serving 30e sentence and he's scheduled
to get out in 20126 he basically had two
years left on his stint he's like
it I'm going for f it or or guess what
you kind of work with the FBI and they
like Hey listen this guy's trying to
talk about he didn't do this there's
evidence that could kind of probably get
him released I mean they wouldn't
release him because of the the After
Shock and BLM would go nuts and antifa
would be so he was an informant is what
he was an inform does he want to be
released indict he led to the
indictments of more than 40 suspected
members of Mexican Mafia this guy when
he gets out he got what do you mean he
just that's attempted murder no what
he's saying is he shot to notor over two
days decades ago after providing
information that led to the indictments
of more than 40 suspected members of the
Mexican Mafia while acting as inform it
according to other times Tom is saying
the day he gets out he's dead so he
doesn't want to get out so maybe he did
this to make sure he doesn't get out
dead dead like a dog does anybody
disagree no I think I think he would
typically have to go to the witness
protection program and they wouldn't
give two shits about him because he's a
former criminal and he would be working
with through the feds at some point he
basically looked at his number he said
I'm out in 2026 either the Mexicans
going to get me or I'm going to get
Derrick shovin over here and I'm going
to take path b or I could or I could
just stay here well but now Shin well
now Shin Like think about the security
that Shin's going to have to have
because now he's he's he's obviously
been a Target now you guys let him get
stabbed that's a that's a it's kind of a
it's a it's a touchy situation I mean
just think about Derek Shin's life for a
second and believe me I'm I'm I'm no I'm
no fan of
chovin three years ago this guy was just
a cop in Minneapolis doing his job made
a idiot move whatever his interaction
was with George Floyd an argument to be
had another day ends up killing the guy
manslaughter whatever he Char help
helping in the death now he's literally
getting potentially stabbed to death
yeah they just one stupid decision in
your life boom and you're done you're
done like face like you canot this guy
for all we know was an upstanding
citizen I don't know his story all I
know is that he murdered George Floyd
that's all I know about this guy he was
a cop in Minneapolis I respect the hell
out of cops we have cops here like no
doubt but now he's getting shanked in
prison yeah and this is what he's
dealing with and that's why he was
trying to appeal Adam he was trying to
appeal that he didn't murder and that
this guy was oding on 90 different
drugs and meth and yeah I mean
by the way if the corner report says
that exfix didn't kill the person and
he's trying to bring that to court and
they don't even want to hear it and then
he gets stabbed that's a lot of weird
things does this help him his case get
out baby not get out Supreme Court the
Supreme Court didn't want to hear him
the solicitor general wouldn't let it
come forward now that he's been stabbed
22 times and almost lost his life maybe
they'll hear it now now no I don't think
is there any empathy or Sympathy For No
but now he's now think about the
protection now Pat now if anything
happens to him after this and he gets
murdered they're going to get sued and
they're it's going to be bad for them
because this was their only shot to kill
him if it was a setup that was their
only shot and this guy dude 22 times and
you don't do the job you're horrible at
your job you're a horrible stabber 22
times you can't you can't finish it no
wonder why the gang doesn't like this
guy I know we're joking but it's this
but still all right Spotify toay off 17%
of a staff it's third round of job Cuts
this year by the way if it seems like
every couple months we're telling the
story and it's not a old story it's a
new story and this is according to wsj
Spotify set to lay another 17% of its
Workforce approx approximately 1,500
employees making his third round of job
Cuts in 2023 as part of an effort to
boost
profitability Co Daniel Le emphasized
the need for cost reduction stating
being lean is not just an option but a
necessity company anticipates incurring
charges of up to €45 million Euros so
$157 million in the first final quarter
of the year due to the layoffs and
expects an operating loss of $93 million
to $108 million during the fourth
quarter revising down its prior forecast
of 37 million operating profit however
CFO Paul vogle remains confident in the
company's profitability projections for
2024 saying we're doing this from a
position of strength Tom are they doing
this from a position of trying to find
some money to pay Joe to renew his
contract what is this all about uh there
may be part of it but there there are
two things going on here one of them I'm
going to cover in a coming week on a
bisoc podcast here from value tment and
that is the first thing's happening is
Spotify is having to rightsize its
finances for two reasons one the under
Ling cost of the music is like 82% so in
other words for every dollar they bring
in they got to pay out like 82% and it
gets carved up in these little pennies
and slices of pennies and sent out to
all the the music acts and and
everything that's first it's the second
of all they're trying to make um a
podcast of success and they've had to
liberate themselves of they made some
Acquisitions that added some fat they
had uh they got rid of the Obamas they
got rid of some people that weren't
performing and they need to resign Joe
Rogan so I think they are trying to
rightsize the company for profitability
and get ready for the signing of Joe
Rogan and point B which I'm going to get
to in in a couple weeks is we're about
to see the consolidation of streaming
services the same way we saw the
consolidation of cell phone companies
that's the way it's going to work who
who's going to be the big dog buying up
uh apple and Paramount plus are going to
get married um or they're going to
consolidate into a single offering and
then split proceeds but offer it as one
offering you're going to see things like
that happen the same way that you saw
look at all everything we saw in the
United States once upon a time we had
singular bought by AT&T right we had
prime primco bought by SBC and thenbc
you think Spotify will be in the buying
or the one being bought uh Spotify is
going to be one of the buyers acquirers
um I look at Pandora is Pandora going to
be there all by itself much longer or
does Spotify kind of absorb that and be
the mega service perhaps but I think
that's the part two part one is they're
trying to right siize their finances and
get ready for the resigning of um Joe
Rogan and they spent a hell of a lot of
money trying to get into podcasting and
a lot of it went bad other than Rogan
who is spotify's biggest content
creators these days I could they have a
lot of them if you go on they have a lot
yeah they have a lot of good ones it's
not like they have one or two but
nobody's close to like Rogan's contract
p is they have Obama and Springsteen
they had Obama and spring kard Prince
fell by the way they they didn't renew
they're like we're moving on you guys
are who who are their biggest people now
other than Rogan um I I I genuinely
don't even know who is it
Robbie they've got a bunch of crime
stuff that does very well they say the
names they're on Spotify like meaning
anybody you say is on Spotify all the
big names are on Spotify is whether no
not exclusive people are people are
screaming it everywhere but you know
they're not you know Spotify unless if
you're willing to pay the kind of money
you pay Joe to some other podcasters
most guys don't want have their podcast
be in one place they had to pay to get
that from correct they are a record
label for Joe Rogan but they are also
the world's largest radio station for
everybody if you want to look at it that
way yeah I'm just wondering who they
paid massive amount of mon money
to spent a billion dollars of marketing
money Harry and Megan they spent a
billion dollars of marketing money and
got uh few names you know and that's
Megan and Harry they got Kardashian they
got Obama and Bruce and they got Rogan
and that was the marketing dollars they
spend when they raise a billion they
need to do that to keep Joe yeah uh
there's plenty of other places that
would love to have Joe there's plent all
those podcasts Rogan's the only one
still standing all those guys basically
they're out yeah the Obamas and stuff oh
yeah for sure nobody who who the hell is
going but as a record label they have a
lot of profitable podcasts that are at
the mid- tier they're very profitable so
Obama's trying to get one of his former
employees to keep his job that's what
he's working on right now who the cook
no no no he's trying to his former one
of his former VPS he's trying to help
him to Jo B sleepy sleepy creepy Joe all
right so let's go to the next story here
next story is Millennials feel abandoned
really by parents not available to help
raise grandkids they're too busy okay
it's a little offensive if you think
about it je all right here we go some
Millennial parents Express feeling
abandoned by their baby boomer parents
who prioritize retirement travel over
helping raise their children
grandchildren Le to scheduling
challenges and resentment psychologist
Leslie Dobson uh notes that many
Millennials develop resentment towards
their parents viewing them as putting by
the way you can tell she's putting that
thought into the kids what do you mean
many so Psy it should be like this
psychologist lesie Dobson AKA divider
notes that as a home recer many
Millennials develop resentment towards
their parents viewing them as putting
their own interests ahead of building
relationships with their grandchildren
during their retirement I'm sure this is
a nice lady Millennials desire regular
stable constant support for raising
their children as childcare expense rise
and workplace demands intensify uh this
desire for emotional child care support
highlights an intergenerational divide
parenting approaches with Millennials
often turning to the internet for advice
instead of their parents Adam you seem
to have an opinion on this one here well
as the oldest Millennial on the planet
all right
1980 um the uh I see what my friends are
all dealing with right now U and they're
juggling kids you know me and Vinnie are
some of the last men standing but we're
accepting accepting
applications um but the um it's no joke
juggling all these kids I just I met
remember I told you the Jamie Diamond
story yesterday I met with a guy who's
super paid up has three kids he's like
I'm like how tough is it he goes I'm
good it's still even tough It's Not Easy
raising kids I'm seeing this and that's
why I'm trying to basically a save up as
much money as possible before I start a
family and B you kind of got to find a
wife too but we're still working L we
figure that out but they're both good
but the reality is raising kids is not
easy and I totally understand where
these Millers are coming from but I will
say expecting the grandparents to raise
your kids for you I how many of you guys
were raised by your grandparents no your
parents do the job of raising the kid so
you know this this kind of similar theme
of entitled Millennials and gen Z they
they're soft you just said the word what
did you say entitles okay here we go
let's go upstream and see who created
this problem what did the parents do
they enabled them they gave them
everything they spoiled them they
shielded they did all that and now they
grow up and they just want more of it
the the parents did this the parents did
this and created these attitudes in the
kids the kids weren't born with these
attitudes they they did that to them
they spoiled them rotten they gave them
everything they sent them to school that
made it worse and now they're coming
home how dare you have a life you used
to give me everything and do everything
and now I'm trying to work when Bab my
kids I got a real question for you I
once asked a guy was speaking he says
how do you judge a great parent he says
by the grandkids he raises grandkids
okay not kids grandkids because that
shows you raise good kids that raise
good kids that's duplication right so
that's how you judge whether you were a
great parent or not so Tom how much of
this is on the parents how much of this
is on the
grandparents do you understand what I'm
asking like and and like for example
Bailey you know she's going to have a
family she's going to have kids is she
going to be like hey Dad can you uh
babysit the kids hey M can you babysit
the kids what are you going to say is
that you're doing or is that Babs doing
that did Babs raise you well or did Babs
get raised well or is it the fact that
you're raising Bailey well I think bab's
raised me pretty darn well and I think
I'm raising Bailey well and what Bailey
if Bailey asks us to babysit or do
things like this it's going to be there
but what these folks are talking about
you're going to be expensive you're
going to be like bucks an hour exactly I
I charge she she have quad you get
massive value like that on man by the
way if you want that that's exactly
right well my babysitting will be done
by manck Bailey will call me a man and
I'll set it up and I'll be there man
that's the way this I respect that
that's the way this is going to work
babysitting no but there's something
here I know that Bailey isn't going to
come back entitled and spoiling and as a
grandparent I will want to spend time I
will want to pour into the Next
Generation
but there
is to pour and respects that are trying
to time with grandparents andal family
love time togetherness and mentoring put
that over here and spoiled freaking
rotten kids that expect the M the their
Boomer parents to give them everything
because the parents did give them
everything and didn't set guard rails
and didn't raise them well and by the
way they're a menace to the rest of
society this this story seems to really
upset you sorry I brought the story up I
just a list of stories that we had yep
anytime Tom references Menace the
society or even boy the hood or calls
LeBron soft you know Tom's on Tom's or
he has a in at 11 o'cl he's trying to
get to it okay next all right so the
santis the santis predicts Iowa win as
political operation backing campaign
fractures this is a Wall Street Journal
not a good word FR Wall Street this is a
Wall Street Journal story uh let's go
through this here he hit all he just hit
All Counties Ronda santz Express
confidence in his chance at iaka stating
we're going to win Iowa it's going to
help Propel us to the nomination but I
think we'll have a lot of work uh that
will have to do beyond that I don't
think you take anything for granted the
santis faces internal turmoil within the
pack uh supporting him as Key Personnel
have resigned or been fired adding to a
picture of this Ray he has been also
seen a decline in Iowa polls with a late
October poll showing him and Nikki Haley
tied at 16% while Trump's at 43 Donald
Trump campaigning campaigns in Iowa
criticizing des santis and Iowa governor
Kim Reynolds for their opposition
stating he seems to be dropping like a
very very sick bird into the
ground I love him go ahead so well I
just I just like Pat and we I think we
we touched on this before this and and
Tom maybe you could help me understand
it okay he's winning Iowa but at the end
of the day Donald Trump is winning by
how many points 40 points 50 points it's
like all these people Christy just did
Christy announce that he's dropping out
too the rumors are that his Camp is
probably not going there's two there's
two things there's a solid rumor backed
up by facts that christe probably is not
going to be on the stage of the next
debate in Tuscaloosa Alabama because he
she's not qualifying for it and then
there's another rumor back there that
says his fundraising is dry and that
people in the campaign are saying Chris
we've gone as far as we can on this one
we had Rob re Chad yesterday for a
comment they said he was doing cardio
but that's uh shut Pat now that is news
you're not going to report hang on hang
on but let's go to the polls can you
play do you have polls or no Tom look
Nikki Haley and Des sis are sitting
there at 16 each but they are both in a
r here's what's happening with Nikki
Haley around Des sanis they're both
about to win the NIT Tournament we're
65th you know that's kind of where where
they're going to be can you do you have
po do you have Iowa polls if you don't
play that clip Rob and then if you want
to go to the polls yeah here we go play
watch this clip uh go for it he looks
shorten the shoulders go well let's talk
about the stakes on caucus night if you
don't come in at least second that's in
would you then drop out of the race how
critical is
Iowa well we're we're going to win the
caucus we we're doing everything that
that we need to do it uh we build I said
from the beginning we we are we are
we're going to win we're going to win
the we're going to win the caucus bottom
line is Iowa Do or Die For You governor
we're going to win Iowa I think it's
going to help Propel us to the
nomination but I think we'll have a lot
of work that we'll have to do beyond
that I don't think you take anything for
granted and I do I do recognize that
there have been people that have wanted
who've not gone on to win the nomination
I think this year's a little bit
different I think the field is narrowed
quicker I think it's going to narrow
even more and ultimately Republican
voters are going to have the choice of
Donald Trump which I think would make
the election a referendum on him uh and
a lot of the issues that he's dealing
with or me uh and that will be a
referendum on Biden's failures on all
the pro issues in the country that are
affecting people and I'll be able to
stand for a positive Vision going
forward so you know you
know like for me I watch interest
declining okay I watch interest
declining I watch one of our guys in our
company he's on stage giving a message
and I'll watch his team's reaction and
I'll notice team's not reacting and I'll
say wow interesting other people are
reacting but his own agency is not
reacting I watch another person get on
stage and they'll speak and I'll say
well look at this everybody's reacting
including his people I'll go to an
office and I'll see the level of
coachability and hunger and desire and
Synergy of everybody working together
you'll feel it from the moment you walk
in I'll sit with somebody who's a direct
report to another person and I'll look
at that person I'm like this guy doesn't
like reporting to this person I look at
a person I'll say with that person
working with this person you can tell
this person loves working with that
person right there's a lot of that
taking
place when when I was talking to Kyle
nek boys one of the questions we asked
about is different candidates and here's
what I said to him I said you can the
great thing about content is you can
tell data tells everything right if you
want to find out what YouTube channels
are dying or what YouTube channels are
doing well this thing's very hard
creating content is very hard staying
relevant and interesting very hard
creating content that gets eyeballs
consistently very hard you know how many
people you're competing with tens of
millions of people who are changing and
if you don't recreate yourself you
cannot stay constantly uh uh winning and
getting eyeballs that is why this is a
very very hard game so watch this if we
were to take Vic's last 50 interviews
and podcast he's done okay let's take
the rfk's last matter of fact let's make
the number easier 20 okay take rfk's
last 20 take vivec's last 20 take
Trump's last 20 take Haley's last 20
take Biden's last 20 take nome's last 20
let's actually look at that together
okay so what are the names we said so
far I said Haley okay the Sanz Vic Trump
Biden Trump RFK and Biden okay Biden and
then uh Nome is what I said yeah or okay
which which of these do you think gets
the most views no matter who interviews
them okay number one is him who's two
it's very interesting what you're going
to say Haley Des santis Vic RFK Biden
Nome guess who number two is
V okay let's put vivec two who do you
think three is would it still be Biden
no Biden doesn't get eyeball I think
it's RFK I think it's RFK but I you know
what when I'm putting RFK who do you
think four is Nome Nome is four who do
you think five
is so so far we have Des santis ncky
Biden I think Nick Nikki is getting more
I don't know I've been seeing more of
him I've been seeing more desanders than
Nikki Haley speak last no okay who do
you have Tom who do you have who do you
have did you order your did you put your
order yeah I've got Haley ahead of Des
santis okay but I'm got got him at the
bottom right where we are I got him at
the bottom anyone below Dan santis no
Biden still gets more eyeball because
he's presid any time he talks I really
have RFK and new some kind of three and
three so check this out here's a
question for you so Jordan Peterson how
big is Jordan Peterson big name how many
subscribers does he have 5 million 7
million plus Subs okay the STIs was on
his podcast yesterday okay how many
views you think this podcast got in 24
hours by the way let me say it one more
time 7 million subs and by the way don't
go there because I don't want them see
it yet yeah 7 million Subs this isn't
like you go on Fox news or CNN that's
got 15 million Subs but they do 50 Clips
a day and one of them doesn't do well no
this is not it Jordan Peterson doesn't
post 20 times a day yeah post once
interview or four times a week or
something like that and this is the
governor of the state of Florida right
running seven 7.2 million Subs how many
views you think it's got 400,000 this a
great question by the way that's that's
a small number because on 7 million okay
400,000 is Vinnie what do you think it
is Tom go first this is 24 hours you
said right I know yeah I'm going to go a
little higher than that like half a
million okay what do you think it is you
said
Al let me tell you something this is in
24 hours be clear here to get a million
in 24 hours is a rockstar interview I'm
going I'm going 200,000 200,000 go to
Jordan Peterson's Channel Peterson on
Rogan will get million in pause it right
there
7.57 million 17 hours ago 86,000 views
that's how that's nothing no by the way
I said 7 million it's 7 and A5 million
so now go to Jordan Peterson's Channel
go to his channel click on the name and
go to V videos zo in a little bit no go
no don't do that go to the latest and
zoom in a little bit zoom in a little so
we can see the video so look at that
86,000 right before that 2.1 million the
freaking comedian yeah 2.1 okay then
138,000 then it goes to
286,000 I you don't know those two names
by the way without a parent then that
guy to left 102,000
85,000 and ran versus whatever
subsidiarity then you got another person
81,000 162,000 what's the next one there
116 580 176 222 to you're the governor
you're the best governor in the last you
crushed it you're running for the
president of the United States not even
that your resume is awesome you crushed
it you absolutely Crush okay I'll do
sometimes I'll do podcast like right and
I'll ask somebody a question and I'll
see the answer they give and I'll tell
myself Yep this is going to be a boring
podcast cuz this guy's going to give
just I just recently had one I know I'm
like okay this guy's going to just give
the vanilla answers cuz he's afraid and
he's scared to talk so because that you
want to be vanilla freaking talk what do
you think about this what do you think
about that give us something right talk
to us well that's because I know what
you're trying to do it's not about I
know what you're trying to do yeah
there's a part of it also of getting
damn eyeballs okay RFK gets eyeballs
okay we're about to have his town hall
when is it uh tomorrow shoot tomorrow
town tomorrow tomorrow afternoon
tomorrow at 2:00 we're doing the RFK
Town Hall sold out by the way sold out
you know the VIPs went like this quick
250 is gone I think I think we got a a
couple hundred General tickets that were
uh uh uh have left for people that if
they want is that what it is yeah
everything else is sold down okay but
people want to know what RFK has to say
people want to know what vivec has to
say why are people not interested in
what the santis has to say and that that
is a part where there is by the way I
watched the whole debate with him and
Nome guess what I watch no I watched the
whole debate and I put my verdict on
social it's it's not even close how much
of a better president the santis would
be than Nome America would be a 50 times
better place than this then new would be
as a as a president and it's not even
close but guess what personality if
there was no radio and TV and social the
santis is the president like this in a
heartbeat there's not even a debate yep
but there's this thing called TV on
social media today you have to sell the
audience I watch a debate the santis
he's a deflector what did I write if you
going to go a little lower what I said
about the santis he know how to spin
every issue he deflected on all issues
he stayed loyal to Biden and Cala he not
once criticized Joe Biden which shows
loyalty to his candidate dodged
questions redirected he bullied the
santis he trolled he stayed cool he sold
fear he pinned the santis against Trump
meanwhile the santis did a great job
selling his argument database telling
stories experien in San Francisco stood
his ground right off the bat he
categorized Nome as someone who spin
every argument great job coming right
off the bat he did the Eminem thing I
can't think of a single argument he lost
logically I respect the fact that he
rised being on stage with Nome so on
Talent Nome won but on policies the
santis on being trustworthy the santis
on more united with his party Nome who
has a better track record of being a
president of course the santis but look
man you you got you almost have to go on
everything you got to talk to your guys
what's a new angle what's a new store
what's a new thing I can get what's the
new enemy what's what's your what's your
what's the what's the enemy because the
angle you're taking with the enemies
you're selling is not resonating and by
the way Governor de santis you didn't
want to read this book choose your
enemies Rob can you make a note we'll
send one of the copies here to to to to
the mansion we were there a few months
ago we'll send it over to him I would
love for him to man like sometimes I
just sit there and think to myself if
someone when when it's coming like Nim's
choosing the right enemies to get under
people's skin Trump is understanding
that part and by the way even haly's
understanding even rfk's understanding
he chose the right enemy is selling it
fouchy all this stuff VC is choosing
that part I I'm I'm not and you called
it you hold on and you called it early
as hell when you were talking about his
team and the the marketing Marketing in
April and then at the end of the day Pat
you can't create you can't learn it
if you 112 yeah if you don't have it and
you you can't you can't recreate that
you can't build that you can't learn you
can't have somebody sit there and be
like hey you're going to get
it just to be clear uh if and when he
doesn't win Iowa his campaign is
finished he's finished already Adam
that's so here we go guys first of all
um uh today's what today's December 5th
5th choose your enemies wisely coming
out today uh I got a report from my
publisher the penguin folks they said we
are very close this week depending on
how this first week goes to being a a
New York Times bestseller and to being a
who knows I mean listen I may need to be
a politically on a different place to be
in New York that they they've prepped me
already be ready for this but it depends
on what happens a lot of the stuff on
strategy business choosing the right
enemies wisely is in this book if you
haven't ordered it yet and you support
our podcast one of the ways to support
is for you to go and order the book and
do the audiobook and you can start
listen to the audiobook right now and
get the physical book as well because a
lot of the charts when you're doing a
strategy book you got to see what's in
the book some of the stuff are charts
some of the stuff are stuff you got to
write in it uh but comes out today for
those who are supporting us uh thank you
for many of you that supported by buying
the book Rob I think we got five of the
winners on uh uh getting a signed copy
that'll be send over to the five names I
have them here if you want to tell us
rob you give us the names sure Ali Keys
lert Kiki Caroline Morton Greg Palmer
and Eda canelson yeah listen Ali Keys
didn't have to write her name the wrong
way she just had to put another I see
Alicia ke I appreciate you for ordering
the book I I am all about women's worth
and uh I have fallen uh in love
with okay all right gang do your thing
uh and uh we will see you again are we
doing another one Rob or actually we got
Tom all right take care everybody bye-
bye bye-
bye